the mission of the Kirby Center is to
extend the college's teaching mission
here to the nation's capital a place
where a proper understanding of the
American founders principles of
constitutional government is much needed
to say the least what American liberals
most need is liberal education deep
reading in the classic works of Western
literature in the speech for the
sesquicentennial anniversary of the
Declaration of Independence President
Calvin Coolidge himself the beneficiary
of a liberal education at Amherst
College said we need a better
understanding and comprehension of our
institutions and a better knowledge of
the foundations of government in general
our forefathers came to certain
conclusions and decided upon certain
courses of action which have been a
great blessing to the world but before
we can understand their conclusions he
must go back and review the courses
which they file in we must think the
thoughts they thought for the American
founders were also the beneficiaries of
liberal education of a kind that was
standard in America in the 19th century
but which nearly disappeared in the 20th
century I can think of no better person
to speak on this subject than our guest
tonight mr. Tracy Lee Simmons who's been
a prominent writer and journalist for
over 20 years
and teaches humanities in the westover
Honors Program at Lynchburg College he
holds a master's degree in classics from
Oxford he's written for newspapers
magazines and journals including the New
York Times The Washington Post the
Weekly Standard the New Criterion and
others he served as an associate editor
for National Review under William F
Buckley Jr he published climbing
Parnassus a new apologia for Greek and
Latin in 2002 which won a Choice Award
for outstanding academic title for that
year he was for many years the director
of the Dow journalism program at
Hillsdale College his topic tonight is
great books for busy people what the
best books teach us every day please
join me in welcoming mr. Simmons
well thank you it's very nice to be back
at Hillsdale and we are at Hillsdale
right I'd like to think of the Kirby
Center as a kind of embassy and so this
is Hillsdale soil and they can't get us
here
so it's been a long time since I've had
anything to do with a Hillsdale event
and as I contemplated this talk this
evening I thought well what makes a
Hillsdale event a hillsdale event and I
thought back to my years there and I and
and I realized somewhere somehow I have
to quote Tocqueville and I've never
really looked for quotations in this way
before but I took down some Tocqueville
and I started paging through this is a
dangerous method and I came across this
sentence and I kid you not to remain
silent is the most useful service that a
mediocre speaker can render for the
public good so I come to you with more
than little humility this evening
do you remember when I guess some of you
can't but over it was over 30 years ago
when we all in this country found
ourselves scared to death over the
nightmare of nuclear annihilation either
accidental or deliberate first there was
Three Mile Island which is a real mishap
at a nuclear power plant and then the
China Syndrome which is a film about a
near fictional massive meltdown and then
early in 1983 came the day after
remember that which was a on television
which was a gruesome drama about a
nuclear exchange with the Soviet Union
and what it might be like for the few
unfortunates who would survive more than
a
a few days or weeks and I remember right
after that film aired that many people
were talking whimsically about what they
would do if they ever heard the siren
sound and knew that all that they had
known and loved would be obliterated in
30 minutes
not a bad mental exercise actually for
concentrating the mind well I cannot
remember my own guess as to what I might
do but I do recall one of my friends
saying that when the signal came when
those sirens sounded he would stoic ly
retire to his front porch with a book of
some kind he didn't say which kind and
read quietly while waiting for the final
flash well none of us can know perhaps
what he or she would do and I rather
suspect that my own response would be
more prayerfully feverish than that but
my friends resolve to remain a civilized
man till the end still sticks in my mind
well I've been set a theme this evening
on great books for busy people which I
hope will not be a great books great
last books for busy people in this sense
and it's a pretty jolly sort of topic
probably tailored design for the very
kinds of people likely to work within 20
square miles of this building so I'd
like to talk about these so-called great
books and what they can bring to our
lives as constant and reliable
nourishment but before I do that I'd
like to talk about why we read or ought
to read at all apart from the
necessities of work and school and
perhaps why I used to see so many people
beyond their youth on the DC metro than
I lived here for 10 years during the
1990s reading books of a demanding kind
of that they were probably they would
probably balked at reading when they
were in college one was war in peace
which I thought an ambitious Troy
for the noisy metro another book
significantly during Desert Storm was
the Iliad these people were no doubt
awfully busy Deezy Deezy people are
though they seem to find time for
reading what exactly were they doing as
they made their way by fits and starts
through those long and challenging books
what was motivating those who might not
get home till 9 o'clock in the evening
or later to take on yet another task
like this well my guess is that many of
them were trying in piecemeal fashion to
get the education they never got at
their expensive schools and colleges and
universities which is an admirable way
to spend one's otherwise dead time on a
subway
perhaps they shared the pangs of
Revolutionary War general Nathanael
Greene when he said and I quote I lament
the lack of a liberal education and feel
the mist of ignorance to surround me now
here is one reason to read great books
just to make our minds somewhat worthy
of the diplomas and degrees hanging on
our walls
venerable documents if you think about
it made to look far older than they are
and that seemed in no way nonetheless to
reflect the manifest disorder and
triviality of our minds so much of the
time no matter how high our IQ they
don't seem to show that one sensed as I
looked at these people on the metro that
their reading was not mere time killing
that's what the Washington Post is for I
always smiled when I saw them and
honored their choices well to me the
question why read great books is closely
akin to why read at all as if you think
about it reading really is
an extravagant use of precious time
after all though it does require real
sacrifices and so those who read only
when they have nothing else to do aren't
really reading perhaps but filling stray
minutes there are surely worse things to
do with one's time but I wouldn't call
such people readers I'm reminded of
Ronald Knox the English priest and
novelist who said that we are living in
a time of loose thinking and unloved
aureus reading well when I speak of
reading here I'm talking about those who
take reading seriously even when they're
reading light breezy work there are
people for whom books make an essential
part of the good and purposeful life not
an ornamental sort of an ornamental
activity meant merely to perhaps impress
other people that benchmark ups the game
ensued Lee for the spare time browser
the people I'm talking about may not be
bookworms but they almost always have a
book simmering at low heat somewhere on
a desk
beside a favorite chair on a bed stand
or in a bag or briefcase or bus or train
commutes and of course then there are
always those good and curious people who
read and read rapidly because as they
often say there's just always more to
know but sometimes what they want to
know may be a little more than a new
series of facts that they can briskly
place and place into a mental file they
want to cut to their own chase and this
is what reading means for many people
and for those people speed is likely
desirable why waste time after all few
of us drive to the grocery in order to
enjoy the view along the way we have a
mission and we want to get there and get
out yet almost all of us are confronted
with the need to
this merely acquisitive attitude to some
of our reading occasionally and and
let's face it certain things like 2,000
page laws passed by Congress locked in
ice floes of turgid prose aren't really
meant to be read by human beings at all
anyway at least not by most of us they
seem to exist more for the sheer bulk of
and for intimidation perhaps and we can
be honest such people such readers
probably make up the lion's share of
readers in most big cities but no matter
how brilliant such people may be certain
kinds of experience and reading will be
forever closed to them poetry for
example a poem will not yield up its
secrets on command to the spirit that
can't wait upon them a poem isn't so
much wood as as red as woud I'd like to
say one may not care for that encounter
of course but the not caring if the non
caring person is a man or woman of
intelligence is something mildly to
regret I think and this brings us back
to the question of why we read again one
reads first of all and I never tire of
saying this for pleasure and as we all
know there are different kinds of
pleasure reading the Great Gatsby gives
us one kind of pleasure
Shakespeare another a well-researched
online article another a penetrating
political commentary another Robert
Frost another and despite earlier
another still I don't place all these
works on the same plane obviously I only
say that they all provide pleasure and
legitimate diversion from the pounding
necessities of life and they might even
help to redeem life now notice that the
possibilities I just cited don't all
make for light reading though most of it
can be approached if you will lightly
that is for the purpose of relaxing or
reflecting
or simply informing oneself not merely
to pass an exam or to gather support for
an academic essay the spirit we adopt in
reading really does count for example
there's pleasure in reading save the
Federalist Papers not the easiest sort
of reading to be sure and I went over
them again this winter and those pieces
by Hamilton Madison and J do require for
most people some explanation or
elucidation from outside in order to
read them a right but the point is that
that book is certainly satisfying for
one who reads it slowly and patiently
and deliberately not only with a mind
for ideas but with an eye for images and
an ear for rhythms the founding writers
really were that good when they put
quill to paper one walks away in other
words with something ample and
nutritious a pretty good meal there it's
nearly impossible to put down
a better more abundant book and feel as
though you've wasted your time
and in case you've not noticed that's
simply not how most valuable time gets
wasted these days but there's a larger
higher more bracing reason to read if
you'll allow me to move into a brighter
he we read because we come from peoples
of the book because that's how we pass
on the tablets of experience because it
isn't enough to know in some disembodied
sense we must be articulate about what
we know and it is the ability to
articulate experience to enshrine that
experience in words and images that
allows us to converse and to pass on
that which we know and feel to others
who come after we also read because none
of us is self sufficient we all come
into this world impove
and selfish and shallow and that's
pretty much the way we stay unless by
regular acts of the will we maintain
intellectual and spiritual health which
may be much harder to maintain than
physical health takes a lot of effort
when we read the better books whether of
history literature letters philosophy or
what-have-you
were reminded that we're not alone and
that others who have traveled this road
before us and that a few of them have
found a few answers to the perennial
questions whether of public or personal
life and that there are answers at least
as plausible as those that people of our
singularly confused time have served up
we also come into this world wired to
the world's frenzy and nonsense reading
work that's pitched above our above well
above us I still think of as an antidote
and a fine one to both our pride and our
anxiety we're reminded that the
obsessions and fears of the day really
are transient or depending on their
nature we learned that they're permanent
in which case trying to solve them as
problems is like swatting fleas some
problems never do get solved only
ameliorated notice that some can learn
that lesson by attentive reading others
only by experience and perhaps the rest
run for political office and please
allow me a digression on words because
words are the medium here I've been
teaching college students off and on for
well over 20 years now and in that time
I've been led to conclude at least two
things first
that students are every bit as
intelligent today as they ever have been
at least in my limited exposure and in
some ways I'm happy to report
I'm a nerd than my peers were and I've
noticed second that their vocabularies
have been contracting steadily that is
the number of words let alone
cultural references from the past that
they're likely to know upon entering
college has been decreasing almost
measurably in fact some analysts believe
they have measured the shift over the
decades by one reckoning the average
vocabulary American adults armed
themselves with ranges between 10,000
and 20,000 words though whether those
figures reflect real word use or real
understanding I don't know the two are
certainly not the same they glanced at a
newspaper online blog or see spam will
tell you that I'm reminded of John Henry
Newman who once said that nothing is
more common for people to think that
because they know what the words are
that they understand the ideas they
stand for
one study in 1984 places the figure of
average vocabulary as high is 45,000
words the one by 1980 1992 suggested the
number to be far lower and closer to
5,000 words now I cannot know the
methods used in these studies and I
customarily cast a gimlet eye on such
things but I suspect the lower figures
to be closer to the truth and they're
getting lower now this condition of
contraction if as I say it exists as I
believe it does should raise alarms for
us and why because words are the
currency of exchange really for thinking
people the fewer words we know the fewer
thoughts we can think and the fewer
subtleties we can express in a phrase
the less intellectually adult we are our
maturity is stunted it's as though
were to reduce one's sense of sight to
primary colors only all other colors and
shades and nuances would be invisible
now
one may be able to function in such a
world true but how much less rich and
how much poorer that world would be but
the stakes may be even higher
time passing and the trend continuing
communicating with others would become
in the future more and more labored
finer shades of meaning and
sophisticated debate and note the
metaphor of the very word shades there
would be strained to the breaking point
and wit would be impossible as a culture
we could all end up back in the second
grade
and I ask you what if there should come
a day when for example the word
unalienable we're two laps out of our
working vocabularies completely which is
to say we might recognize the sound of
it perhaps even be able to take a jab at
what it means but we couldn't quite
define it to a sixth grade teacher
satisfaction how then would we read the
Declaration of Independence just what
does that peculiar word modifying those
rights in unalienable rights mean the
answer is that we would likely settle
back comfortably into an easy chair of
soft ignorance and consent to let the
experts deal with all that but then some
people think that that time has already
arrived and if that should be true even
somewhat true incipient ly true the
Republic may be in more than a little
danger if we are to take seriously mr.
Jefferson's warning that those who
expect to remain both ignorant and free
expect what never was and never will be
putting a sharper point on this same
thought Jefferson also told us that
no nation is permitted to live in
ignorance with impunity we pay the
penalty eventually in other words a tiny
innocent and seemingly insignificant
slide away from literacy like this
a forgotten word here a words meaning
stretched to the snapping point there a
word indifferently grasp could not too
far down the road compromise our very
citizenship because if we lose the
meaning of the word unalienable we could
also lose the meaning of this grand
experiment in government one that's been
sustained for almost two and a half
centuries now pretty high stakes indeed
education really is that vital to the
life of this country so here's to the
good and valiant teachers among us and
again if people's vocabularies are
really contracting nowadays is not that
an odd thing to be happening in an
assimilative time when technology is
busy about augmenting the language with
so many new terms how could this
possibly be one guess I'll make before
going on is the surmise that we're
giving less attention to words to their
meanings to their histories to their
sounds to their rhythms to their
textures in our homes and our schools
and in our lives it's not enough to know
what words mean of what they can mean
and to see them not on dry antiseptic
word lists but in action scampering
about and their native habitats this is
what it really means to read seriously
here certainly is not an easy easily
soluble problem
I'll call how exactly do we restore that
ethos to our society and to our culture
the answer to that is we cannot we can
do
so individually and who can know where
that solitary effort might lead
certainly if people read more that is if
they invited more quiet and reflection
into their loud cluttered worlds
besieged with misused words then the
power of words properly and artfully
employed could reassert itself and
behind every new word learned a new
thought a new expression a new idea
might be waiting and one that we could
have owned long before had we discovered
it earlier this is the treasure that so
many of us let's sit outside our doors
in the cold and it needn't be that way
ah but enough of that I was talking just
now about the about a few of the
advantages of reading great books well
here is another independence not only do
we achieve an independence of mind but
in some real sense an independence from
our own time or at least the means of a
respite from it if we think about it we
recognize that so many great people of
the past were great precisely because
there was something about them that was
timeless something about them that was
untethered they were not always locked
into the mores and expectations and
assumption of their era as lesser people
around them were they could think as
passionately detachedly they could see
possibilities
not to mention absurdities more clearly
reading can do this for us too for
instance a couple hours spent with
Dickens hard times and free us from a
few of the reigning assumptions of our
own time and helped us to see our own
world in a new revelatory light we
become less chained to our own day and
confined sympathies and insights within
ourselves of which we might not have
expected ourselves capable this
is more than an intellectual edge it's
an enhancement of life and yes we learn
more many more words we began to see the
world both as we wish it to be but also
as it is reminded of these words of
Henry James every talk on great book
should include at least one quotation
from Henry James who wrote not in one of
his novels but in one of his reviews
this passage I find still haunting this
is what his reading his study of history
has taught him that evil is insolent and
strong beauty enchanting but rare
goodness very apt to be weak folly very
apt to be defiant wickedness to carry
the day imbeciles to be in very great
places people of sense in small and
mankind generally unhappy that's one
sentence as we like to say sometimes
hard liquor on that one so I wanted to
get a little light and talk about what
busy people should do with their reading
lives so I've brought Tracy's ten points
every one and this is the city four
points and bullet points of other kinds
so we finally get to the bone at this
talk how do we find time to devote to
books however good or great when we're
still finding time to stop by the dry
cleaners after work well there's no
easier one way to answer this but I'll
begin with a reminder from the poet
William Blake we become what we behold
we become what we behold another way of
saying that for our purposes maybe we
are but we read so point one choose
wisely
stand back and think about how little of
your time you have to lend to Sirius
reading and don't just consider this
generally count up the hours monthly
weekly daily estimate that number of
hours that you have for reading per week
and you'll see that even if you're an
industrious reader able to snatch odd
moments with the book while standing in
line at the post office something I
cannot do still those hours are limited
do your best always recalling Mark
Twain's declaration that the man who
does not read good books has no
advantage over the man who cannot read
them or to vary the thought I think it
was Henry Harry Truman who once said
that every book is a new book to someone
who hasn't read it so how many hours do
you have for reading per week 20 + 6 -
what's the matter in a truer light I
think for each of us and that's why we
must choose judiciously
I rarely advise anybody to adopt someone
else's list of must read books but
depending on the advisor there are worse
ways know for entrance interest first
don't pick up as I saw a friend of mine
do a few years ago The Wealth of Nations
by Adam Smith just because many imposing
people are doing so pick it up only if
you feel some real impulsion to read it
and a fascination with economic theory
wouldn't hurt when we pick up books too
far outside our Ken we run the risk of
frustration and burnout so pick and stay
with whatever you imagine you'll be
itching to get back to in spare moments
and
finish it and finish it in the interests
of self-respect above all don't make
time for reading I hear people say that
all the time I'm gonna I'm gonna make
time for reading don't make time take it
take it
budget your days and weeks in as and in
such ways as to make reading at least as
important as going to the gym remember
that whatever we're not sacrificing for
really isn't all that important to us
second point if you've been out of
regular serious reading for a while get
back in the swim with books written in
periods that fascinate you like 16th
century England or 19th century Russia
Tolstoy Dostoyevsky and Chekov would
keep you busy for quite a few fiscal
years
if you end up catching their bug and
categories count - why should we
exclusively read one work of say history
after another there's nothing wrong with
that of course but I would only say that
if history is your fort try also to read
historical accounts written during or
close to the period being examined
reading too much contemporarily written
history runs the risk of seeing that
time exclusively through the lenses of
our time which isn't the idea we're not
quite the idea of gaining intellectual
independence third point if you're
especially ambitious depart from your
field of familiarity if you're most
uncomfortable with history for example
if you're most comfortable I should say
with history make a point of reading a
novel and reading it well Willa Cather's
my antonia will tell you just as much
about the prairies during the second
half of the 19th century in the united
states as will any study of the place
and period and perhaps more
or as Cather stills essences this is the
power of art it's also one of those
books you'll look forward to rereading
footnote that's another significant
understanding we need to bear in mind
about serious readers they reread things
once someone was interviewing CS Lewis
about some book or other and said
professor Lewis have you read that a
certain book by so-and-so and Lewis's
answer was oh I've read it yes so no I
think it was Nabokov later I said that
in a strange way books cannot be read
they can only be reread paradoxically
true I think well this is also my
Antonia one of those books you'll want
to reread time and time again and again
I I use these examples of books that
I've been looking at within the last 12
months myself or read the Adams
Jefferson correspondence you'll get lots
of history there and much else besides
but if you're more at home with novels
if you're one of those people maybe a
shot at political theory maybe just the
thing Rousseau's long treatise called
discourse on the origins and basis of
inequality among men might put you in
thicker weeds but reading that work
alongside his Emil will give you an
understanding of the political
left-right divide that you could gain
really in no other way and if you're a
policy wonk if you're a policy wonk read
poetry which will give you one of the
very few inducements in your life to
humility as a reminder that no matter
how much the machinery of state and
society be tinkered with mystery remains
indeed
mystery will out as its once said poetry
emboldened the soul to accept mystery
you'll also enjoy a relief from the
inflated formulations of policy prose
and be reminded of how real people sound
good and bad sophisticated and
unsophisticated fourth point I will get
to the end some wish to keep their
private reading private a refuge from
the opinionated talkative atmosphere we
breathe every day
others though wish to impart what
they're reading to others enrich
discussion and if you are so inclined
find intelligent receptive ears they too
they latch on to your secret and start
reading again and this is how many
people pick up what they missed while
sleeping in class fifth point I before
of bed stand reading but beware of
leaving your most serious reading to
that time of day when wine has already
bestowed its blessings on mind and
spirit Moby Dick requires more than a
modicum of alertness so does Dante
Sixpoint don't forget that we do we go
to great books not only to find
parallels between our lives and the
times of those of others but also simply
to stir our selves in the very other
nough souther a place where the current
effluvia of pop culture cannot intrude
soak yourself in that other nests and
return with a freshen view of your own
time and then a formidable task see how
much you can integrate some of that
other nests some of that strangeness
into your own life
it was it was Thomas Jefferson again who
once said that it's the object of deeps
and thought to integrate knowledge into
the personality at that not just
integrate knowledge into the mind
integrated into the personality try that
and 7-point read deliberately take a
year on one book if that's what it takes
to receive it with something like
completeness glory in it reread vast
sections before going forward only a
perverse age could put such a premium on
speed recall the words of Aldous Huxley
to be well-informed one must read merely
informative books to be cultivated one
must read slowly and with the lingering
appreciation eighth point despite what I
just suggested about the comparative
equality of all genres keep in mind a
study once cited by The Economist
magazine concluding that those people
possessing the largest vocabularies are
those who read fiction mainly because
fiction tends to use a larger range of
words this may explain of course why
some people prefer nonfiction but that's
a bad bargain the payoff and the
pleasure with imaginative literature is
far greater a fact once confirmed by the
civil war historian Shelby Foote who
once told me that his training as a
novelist served him far better in
writing his massive three volume
narrative of that war than any secondary
works of scholarship he consulted so if
you're not a reader of fiction read one
novel per year anyway but make it a good
one fear not the big book CS Lewis said
in one of his letters the great beauty
of long books is that however often you
have read them there are still large
tracts you have forgotten
you ever heard someone say of a
particular book oh yes I've read that as
though it's it's been drained of all of
its juice it's no longer real for them
did you read Hamlet oh yes 11th grade as
those are saying never touch that again
whereas in fact it might take a lifetime
to appreciate a play like that with
anything like fullness so as I say make
the novel you choose a good one a very
good one and a long one ninth point
remember that the main idea is to find
yourself doing commerce not only with
the ideas as you read an understandable
fixation for the politically engaged but
with words words and all their power and
variety and color so keep a notebook to
remind yourself of salient bits
sentences praise its words from each
book so that you won't lose all its
substance with time after a few years
you may find that this notebook will
amount to an intellectual memoir of
yours a reminder that your life way back
when was not merely a formless mess of
one meeting after another but that it
had ballast it had weight oh yes I
remember the summer of 2015 you may say
that was the summer of Henry Adams and
Faulkner there really are worse ways to
earmark our days and tenth and final
point reading the great books is simply
another way of extending experience
remember that it's been said that and I
think it was Ortega y Gasset
who said this that culture is what's
left over after everything we've read
has been forgotten
it's the residue the unarticulated
survival a Frenchman one
is called memory the nerve of
understanding I've never forgotten that
the nerve of understanding we read in
that little book some of us read in
school called 1066 and all that I don't
know if you ever read that there's a
marvelous sentence there to the effect
that history is not what happened it's
what you can remember history is not
what happened it's what you can remember
by this standard history does not even
exist for many people and that is a
frightening thought if this be true the
very act of reading a good or great book
can be an exercise in reclaiming memory
and in the end to reclaiming a culture
worth preserving
and it also ennobles us thank you
current tsunami of Technology has on on
reading it seems to me now with texting
and YouTube and all this that young
people have a daughter and they're
absorbed in this and the hours they
spend watching silly videos and things
it's just mind-blowing and you know do
you see that as a problem and what
should we do about it
well my moderate response to that is to
say that the road to hell is paved with
good inventions I think it I think it's
terrible I do hesitate to say it because
I'm of an age now where I don't want to
seem older than I am but I do when I'm
walking across a college campus and I
see everybody on a phone everybody's on
a phone everyone's texting or we're
looking for something or other on Google
or shopping for something they're not
really alone a lot of people don't take
long walks anymore we have a marvelous
trail down where I live and people will
be texting along this nature trail or
they'll be listening to something their
ears and and of course it's it's a
spring day there are certain birds out
you haven't heard for many months but
they'll never hear them so the the
problem of technology is is pervasive I
I'd like to be a good Aristotelian and
and believe that that nothing of itself
is bad just in itself that there are
good uses to be put to all these things
I don't think anything's evil but they
the gadgets do make it easier for good
people to waste their time in the
generation before it was television that
could waste the time in the generation
before that it was radio that could
waste the time or movies I could raise
the time or comic books I could waste
time
but you don't want to assume any
equality there because it's you use the
word tsunami I think I think that's
accurate I do tell us I tease them
really I don't I don't anything I say I
want to make more like a something a big
brother would say but I I do challenge
them sometimes to turn off their phones
for an entire day and some tried it
more than half enjoyed it all said it
was difficult because it's it's an
addiction it might be a benign one but
it is an addiction but that comes to the
point of time if you have and some of
them some of us at any time of our lives
we may have only a two-hour window a lot
of people say they don't have time to
read and then you'll hear about the
things they do
clearly disposable things they say oh I
would love I wish I had more time to
read I love to read no you know they
don't I tell them no you don't what do
you it's the first thing I ask what are
you giving up in order to read and
they'll often be unable to say anything
so they really don't want to read I
always like to have something brewing
all the time
I travel with books I don't when I'm
traveling I don't get to read them very
much but I like to have them there and I
wish more young people would take that
attitude some are returning to that
though I read something few months ago
to the effect that college students are
college aged people today are reading
more actual books and issuing some of
the electronic devices for reading them
so I do know I can name probably five
people around 20 years old who have
gotten rid of Kendal's and nooks and so
forth and because they prefer they have
of a real book so I don't think we're
without hope but if you are 20 years old
and you've grown up in a world with that
that has always had the internet and has
always had these these little toys about
I imagine it's pretty hard to get rid of
them
hey Tracy I'm just curious hello Betsy
I'm just curious if there's a book from
the last five years like one or two
books that's been recently published
that you like the most or that you think
is maybe a good example of contemporary
book writing I was a book reviewer for
so many years and for a period of that
time in the early 90s I reviewed nothing
but new novels and so when I didn't have
to do that anymore I stopped reading a
lot of Contemporary books so I suppose
the answer to that would be some of the
some of the books I've I've had to
review for the poster somebody odd
there's a nice book by about Prince
Phillip I thought that that was
revealing about a lot of 20th century
global politics even and something I
didn't particularly expect so but I
haven't really really read too many
contemporary books I'll think of
something as soon as I go on to another
question but since I'm teaching history
and literature and philosophy believe it
or not now I'm my mind is in is in amber
it's in another time in a sense
if a newspaper is the first draft of
history as it's been said and our
younger generations no longer read
newspapers they won't even have the
memory that you called history
especially if they're getting their news
from the comedy shows but another
question that I've heard and maybe you
can answer this we may be raising a
generation of people who only go to the
internet for source material leaving
many many answers tucked away on the
shelves of a college library that no
longer has visitors I I sense that all
the time my students when they have to
write a paper will go immediately to
Google and they'll tell me well I had
time I had a hard time finding this or
that and I said well what did you find
in the library it didn't even go they
didn't even darken the door of the
library I said you you're missing so
much by simply being able to browse
through the stacks you know you'll find
something that you weren't looking for
and it's just the thing you actually
want it's the thing you actually need
and you wouldn't have known it was there
so that that would I suppose that would
be another way of answering this
gentleman's question that technology is
is not is really is doing a number on
our deliberative nasai dia being that a
lot of people if they're 19 or 20 they
think that everything really is at their
fingertips it's all there
they don't realize that certain things
need to be edited that not all knowledge
is equal that's something I'm fighting
with students that they if it's all on
the Internet it's all equal it doesn't
matter who it doesn't matter where it
comes from it doesn't do the provenance
doesn't matter at all if it's on the
Internet everything is of a kind of
equal
quality and I I find that disturbing and
I do try to rub up against it but it's
hard to do because not all of their
instructors may be doing the same thing
this is a question from our Twitter
audience what is your what is your list
of 10 books to be reread more than once
for every man of letters say it again
what is your 10 books to be reread more
than once for every man of letters
Edmund Burke's reflections on the
revolution in France
I read that about 25 years ago in a very
summery fashion and I didn't quite
understand it and I've read it again
within the last year or two and it's
been a marvelous experience that's
something I want to keep reading I don't
have a list of ten books I have read
Gibbons decline and fall of the Roman
Empire that several volumes I don't
intend to do it again unless I'm in
prison mm-hmm
oh well of course but I teach Plato and
Aristotle is ethics I am with dr. Arnn
on that one that's something that I
teach every year the whole book not not
that's a marvelous one I was reading the
age of revolution volume last week I
wanted to see what he thought of the
French Revolution so that's a marvelous
one but he had some sympathy for them
though it was a marvelously nuanced view
of it you know oh I'm not off the hook
there I would welcome anyone's
suggestion of other books because my
every every reader is going to have an
eclectic list so I'm a classicist by
training so I
I'm going to say Plato and Virgil and
Aristotle and Aeschylus and Aristophanes
I'm going to say Senecas letters Aquinas
absolutely the Latin is beautiful by the
way you need it your you need a
particular Latin dictionary to read a
coin as well and I have not read an
entire but maybe a hundred pages in the
Latin and many more in translation so
anything by Aquinas the the Summa you
have to be in a certain mood I suppose
to read Aquinas a philosophical mood
Dante absolutely now there's there's an
example of someone I've not read in six
or seven years eight years that's
getting to be too long so I would add
Dante to that it's sort of like the
desert island books where were they
where they simply say okay we give you
the Bible and we gave you a Shakespeare
now get to it what would you Boswell's
life of Johnson I would add to it and
went on a trip to Italy and Greece about
three months ago and I was there for
three weeks four weeks or so and I took
that with me
and that's very good company practically
anything by Dickens Proust I I'm a very
strange reader in that way I love Proust
I've gone through all of that twice but
that's but many volumes and I do want to
go through that again
I could I could stand not to not to read
Gibbon again but I would hate to think
I'm going to I would be on my way to to
death without reading Proust one more
time I think I would leave the list
there
I'm an early riser I usually wake up
between 4:30 and 5:00 and I like to read
and bed a little bit and then late
afternoon and then evening but if I'm
going to have a nice long evening of
reading I don't give myself wine for
dinner because I need to elongate the
evening is as much as I can so early
morning late afternoon early evening
would be my optimal time but but
people's metabolisms metabolisms are
different so I I don't know but that
would be for anyone else
like me you didn't touch on this but I
just want you to agree with me on this
that one of the things that I think is
really missing in getting information on
computer is there's no tangential
learnings what you talked about or
alluded to and going into the list acts
and you find all sorts of things that
you didn't know you needed to know and
it was wonderful that way and I have
such a hard time getting my daughter to
use a dictionary or encyclopedia she
goes to the computer but you know I
can't every time I open encyclopedia
dictionary I always learned something
more than what I thought I was just
looking for and I think that's a
tremendous dimension of learning that is
that is being lost on yeah although I
would be happy with some of my students
would look up things on the computer
sometimes I I have four four readings
for instance on a particular day we're
going to read so many chapters of this
or that and I'll say to them we're going
to have a quiz that's gonna be on
nothing but vocabulary nothing I'm not
asking you any profound questions about
meaning I just want to know that you
know every word in those two chapters
that is if you weren't familiar with a
particular word I want you to look it up
and I want you to write it down and some
of them will say well do you do that I
said I do it all the time I still keep
notebooks I write down new words all the
time and usually words that amuse me
like hypergamy it's a marvelous word for
marrying above yourself it's not
marvelous the idea is good enough but
we've got a word for it thank you